as you can imagine it's been a very busy
day
where myself and my senior team have
worked with what we call our strategic
coordinating group
which features all the senior a number
of the senior leaders in the island
including various government departments
obviously fire ambulance colleagues as
well as we provide a coordinated effort
to deal with the the tragedy that
occurred this morning
we have now had four strategic
coordinating groups where we've made
quite significant progress some of which
I'll give in a short while
but of course we plan for this we have a
major incident manual and we practice
these things and so therefore we should
be ready and indeed I'm satisfied that
we are
importantly uh there is also the
sensitivity of dealing with a brief
families and friends and as I mentioned
previously we've deployed uh specially
trained police officers family liaison
officers to the town hall to provide
support to those people that will
continue that will continue uh Way
Beyond the sort of search and rescue
phase of this particular incident
uh similarly with the uh and I'm very
grateful for the chief Minister's
comments uh a number of Staff have
worked very long days throughout the
night and into today and I play
Testament to their um determination to
do what is right and I think we've seen
that across all of the emergency
services and indeed I thank other
emergency service colleagues for the
response but of course this is a
protracted incident
this is going to go for days maybe weeks
and therefore it's important that we
have the resilience to continue and keep
going so this isn't going to finish
today as I'm sure you probably
understand
also reinforcing the chief Minister's
comments have the amount of support not
only that we have received from in the
island I indeed have received text
messages from hotels asking to offer
accommodation and the like that is
typical in my view and my experience of
Jersey when when we are in difficulty
people pull together and I have seen an
enormous amount of that uh this at this
last sort of 24 hours or so we've also
had significant support from the UK
particularly from Hampshire in the Isle
of Wight and the southwest region and
indeed military liaison who are
providing us with specially trained
people who are searching as we speak and
they will be doing a number of trips
this evening to provide specialist
equipment that that has been very
generous generally genuinely and
generously provided to us I'm enormously
grateful for that
so to conclude the important thing now
because of those assets and because of
those specially trained men and indeed
to search dogs as well we will continue
to search throughout the night with the
appropriate lighting and appropriate
safety of our teams and I I am really
pleased that we can do that particularly
in the interests of families at that
point I'll now hand over to Paul
thank you Robin and like Robin I'd like
to Echo the words of the chief minister
and express my sincere condolences
for the loss of of Islanders in this
tragic incident
um
there are currently four Urban search
and rescue Specialists including a
tactical advisor working at the scene
and have been undertaking searching
activity for some time there are they
are accompanied by at the moment 16
states of Jersey Fire and Rescue service
Personnel we are expecting uh and I
think they have already landed in Jersey
a further five Urban search and rescue
Specialists as well as some search dogs
which are routinely deployed in these
sorts of incidents later on this evening
I am expecting a further wave of urban
search and rescue Specialists to arrive
in the island with the necessary heavy
USA equipment as it's called
um as you'd expect Urban search and
rescue means that these are specialist
firefighters trained to deal with these
sort of situations and conduct search
operations and create safe spaces to
conduct those search operations and also
create space for other Emergency
Services Personnel notably hazardous
area Response Team paramedics and and
the chief ambulance officer will talk
about that as well so the urban search
and rescue Personnel have been provided
by Hampshire and the Isle of Wight fire
and rescue service and of course I am
very grateful for their very prompt
support to my request in the early hours
of this morning
also that we have a lot of national
support being galvanized and organized
around the foreign rescue service sector
both to us but also importantly to
Hampshire in the yard of white foreign
rescue service
um the nature of the work is necessarily
slow and methodical and I know that you
will appreciate that that is the case
and why that is the case
um
the the plan is that we will continue
searching and we have no other plan at
this stage we are just continuing to
search and most of our efforts at the
moment are about the organization and
Logistics of securing the right support
at the right time and making sure the
right equipment arrives in the right
sequence that's critical for us for a
more successful operation if if it can
be successful the the area is being lit
and teams will be working tonight all
night and we will not stop
for the time being
thank you
thank you ladies and gentlemen I'd like
to Echo my condolence as well to the
families and those involved as my
colleagues and the chief minister has as
well so our teams have been on scene
since the early years of the morning uh
around 4am this morning we were
fortunate enough to get some Crews on
scene very quickly and officer support
and additional Crews called in to assist
um
we were able to triage those casualties
that we met us on arrival and those
survivors that were walking away from
the scene and were able to
assist them in the uh in those early
stages
we've been rotating our crews to ensure
our commanders are able to get some rest
and make sure they are fit to continue
in doing their duties throughout the day
and ensure all resources are on hand to
assist when required
we're working closely with the other
Emergency Services ensuring enough
medical resource on scene to manage the
incident at all times
we've had support from our voluntary
Partners our own ambulance support unit
St John Ambulance Normandy rescue and
others that have volunteered and come in
to assist us
we are in contact with the national
ambulance resilience unit and the
national ambulance coordination Center
to coordinate assets from the UK and our
hazardous area response team has come in
from Southwest Ambulance Service to
assist and are all night and assisting
firearm Rescue Services with their
search efforts and will continue to do
so as the other services will throughout
the night we are also still in contact
about other teams potentially coming in
to support that effort so that we can
keep going throughout the night and the
following days if necessary
we're also working on ensuring that we
can get enough command support to
continue those efforts with the small
teams that we have
I am extremely grateful for the
cooperation of everyone involved and
particularly my teams and all the
volunteers and of all the offers of help
and support that we've had so far thank
you